comment réanimer un enfant qui ne
respire plus un bébé qui étouffe c'est à
force d'être confrontée à ces questions
que Déborah Agnès infirmière de
profession a décidé de créer des
ateliers sur ces thématiques ce matin au
programme pour les parents de jéléna un
atelier pour apprendre les gestes de
premiers secours donc en fait le but ce
sera de tirer en gros de
prendre et on revoit en gros qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoque comme risque
on voit qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre en
place parmi les incidents fréquents les
étouffements avec les petits objets les
brûlures ou encore les chutes sont
souvent source d'inquiétude chez les
parents
l'escalier
on en a deux qu'on a les escaliers
classiques barré tous ces premiers
étages on a aussi première étage où les
combles ou c'est vraiment des escaliers
où il y a pas de rebords il y a un trou
entre chaque marche d'accord du coup on
va devoir installer les barrières un peu
partout
[Musique]
il faut savoir que la chute c'est
l'accident numéro 1 le but de ces
ateliers n'est pas de culpabiliser ou
d'effrayer mais plutôt de prévenir les
risques pour mieux les anticiper donc là
en l'occurrence avec les escaliers c'est
barrière en haut barrière en bas
obligatoire si on en met que une en haut
quand elle va commencer à grimper des
fois juste une chute de deux marches ça
suffit après plusieurs années
d'expérience aux urgences l'infirmière
souhaitait donner un sens différent à
son métier à travers la pédagogie
l'échange et la pratique comme avec
cette simulation d'étouffement
de gravité dans l'urgence on le
positionne comme on peut d'accord
voilà exactement le but c'est de
redonner confiance aux parents et
justement leur donner des clés des
outils pour que on n'arrive pas aux
gestes d'urgence voilà leur dire un
accident reste un accident quoi qu'il
arrive il y a des choses qu'on peut pas
prévoir qu'on peut pas contrôler mais on
essaie de mettre en place ce maximum de
choses pour éviter que il y ait une
brûlure qui est tel type de chute des
gestes qui peuvent s'avérer essentiels
en 2022 un million 700 000 accidents ont
été recensés pour les enfants de moins
de 15 ans 48% d'entre eux se produisant
à la maison
[Musique]